well ladies and gentleman Friday I want
to apologize for getting this podcast
out a little late I was working Brennan
had to go to freezing Edmonton where is
now I guess it was three degrees
whoo-hoo what a blast oil fields love
the people of Edmonton before we get
started guys
reminder cap cities Austin I'm there
January 31st first and second I'm kind
of excited because Tim Kennedy's coming
oh yeah
my boyfriend and he promoted my show on
my Instagram story I thought it was
really cool of them hell yeah I like I
get a giddy kind of feeling when I'm
that great MMA fighters and great
Americans great human beings yeah
American comedy club in San Diego
February 7 8 9 mmm and by the way this
just in the vogue theater one night only
Vancouver February 21st the vogue
theater one night only Vancouver I'm
putting it putting up on the tea fat K
website haven't done it yet but you can
get tickets and I'll I'll provide a link
well we're waiting for Will Sasso right
now that's like well as usual is late
the only person who's more late than I
am is Will Sasso I got a text that said
15 cont and he also said to have a
wallet station set up and asked me if
our omelet chef can make crepes
so that would be me then yes so he's
gonna come in like the blazing a hole
that he is by the way I want to thank
everybody because skooled crush ratings
crushed they had no idea it'd be that
big we retained a hundred percent of our
Goldbergs audience and so all these
other things like all these other
reviews so it's kind of weird success is
weird I just want to say this to you
guys success when you get everything you
want you better be careful because it
comes with responsibility
it comes with work and you have to give
something up for something else like I
love that I get to be on a TV show don't
kid me don't get me wrong I love that
I'm writing finally new stand-up it's
all good man it's all good I love my
podcast but it's a lot and you're
juggling a lot
and then when you throw in the little
details of life like I don't know like
figuring out what the setlist is for my
special or some or the the cover art all
that stuff or people want favors and you
want to do them favors and you know but
it's it just literally every minute of
your day gets you know piled on mmm and
then you just want to kind of uh you
want to retreat to your couch and smoke
some weed and smoke my weed
and just be a slacker but I don't oh
dude my kids got that oculus rift dude
that the the virtual reality I got I
tried that rollercoaster [ __ ] I had to
pull it off I almost threw up I just got
scared those things - oh I can't stand
virtual reality I get sick it looks too
real I mean it makes you feel like
you're gonna fall down or you can't walk
around it throws me off what torture
would be to have me be you know sort of
on a roller coaster are one of those
moving things and just be sick all the
time
mm-hmm the worst t-h-e worst I want to
do virtual reality though where I'm
where like I can physically move around
like I can fight I can hunt I want to do
stuff like that when you still feel
weird about the like if you're in a room
feel like you're about to fall out of a
well they say kids should only do two
half hour out of time otherwise they'll
get all crazy that makes sense yeah but
but the promise kids get kids like this
whole new movement of iPads / virtual
reality kids are gonna mesh with
machines so it's and I'm trying to fight
it but how the hell do I fight like
these insane video games these games and
the kids I'm not that entertaining I
can't do what you know all these virtual
reality technicians can do dinosaurs I'm
not I'm not as entertaining as [ __ ]
dinosaurs coming at you at 100 miles an
hour so that's a problem I'm gonna write
about that in my standup perfect how'd
you like your show it was good I mean
you did did you see I'm sure you saw I
can't stand anything I do dude really
yeah but I thought the show was good I
think it's a really good show and it
gets better it gets funnier and it gets
better we had to put in a lot of
information oh and oh I don't know if I
can even say this but well one of the
songs in the pilot
may or may not have been an art Kelly
song what yeah they made it then and and
these incredible editors were like let's
get this song out of here what all the
information came out of that a whole I'm
surprised has taken this long for that
guy to come down yeah he's a really
really creepy weird dude he is right
even since the beginning we first heard
about he's peeing on like young girls
well that I mean it wasn't there a video
of him peeing on a mural so if that's
the case to me that like the fact that
guy like somehow had a career after that
forget the me to movement I know was
before that but like when I heard that
if that's really what he did then I
write that dude off forever
yep I don't know how to what are you
talking about you what
like if I I had my best friend I found
out he peed on a fourteen-year-old I'd
be like I can't be friends with you
anymore I can't okay yeah weirdo old now
there's it says that there's a criminal
investigation finally a probe finally
yeah finally the weird thing about a lot
of this is that a lot of the girls are
young from what I understand and they
they get that Stockholm Syndrome
like there's this thing about I'm that
he probably preys on girls with low
self-esteem and then he then he they're
his captives and whenever you do that
with somebody they feel like a piece of
[ __ ] to begin with so they're not gonna
they're not gonna stand up for
themselves
mmm-hmm so people like that prey on that
[ __ ] they only have people like that can
only have relationships have known
people like this my life they can't have
they can't have you no one like
relationships that are on the same level
they always have to be above somebody
always it's what drives them yeah they
don't they don't have like sociopaths
don't have an ability to empathize or to
actually have a relationship on equal
footing
they only relate to people in terms of
power they have to be in a position of
power over you that's why they say like
sociopaths Psychopaths kill animals
torture animals when they're kids
because it's their it's their ability to
have complete and total dominance and
power over the animal and take its life
that makes sense
yeah do you remember him do you know
that girl Aaliyah yeah singer she's
beautiful
that Romeo Must Die movie yeah oh here
we go here is oh here is what what bro
what is it yeah I know but that was for
other people so come on in will where
you been shooting your eyes are kind of
dead this morning well ah that's
annoying oh my god can you not bring a
an office size cooler jug of water get a
bigger chair these chairs constrain my
hips
I'll do the way that I'm not comfortable
with well I can't I can't bring in a
bigger chair for you just because
getting bigger chairs for Boethius well
Brendan's a big guy he's got a big
athletic high bubble but he does how he
that's how he [ __ ] trains that's how
he beat the [ __ ] out of people yeah he's
got her years and years I got a high
athletic bubble but yeah but it's little
and cute little cute bubble but Brian
Callens ass
that's the but the fits in a red chair
no sass what how long has it been going
this mom well it's been going on for
about five maybe ten minute yeah well
Happy New Year bro thanks buddy I really
really appreciate thank you for having
so much I'd like to say hello to all
your listeners of course yeah they're
there people that I adore they're people
that I feel close to and more
importantly they feel close to me
yeah and that's my responsibility that's
why I showed up today okay when you
asked it has nothing to do with our
[ __ ] French okay okay
hours and years of that all right
because I respect these people yeah I
never know what I'm dealing with with
you because you tend to float from mood
to mood so I yeah I don't know what
I'm coming I don't know what when you
come in I don't know what kind of cloud
I'm gonna have to deal with you know
what I'm saying bro I'm predictable you
could call it exciting but sure there's
a larger logic worm swimming around in
my brain yeah there's a logic worms and
you don't know where it's gonna stop now
what's that logic do you ever just want
to kill a bunch people yeah sometimes I
just want to I just want to slide into
the I just want to go into the forest
yeah and I just want to get I just want
to get people and I want to put them in
cloaks oh boy and I want to and I want
to preach to them and I want to promise
them things so you want to create a
druid Society I want to create a druid
Society and a cauldron we would have a
cauldron what would be in said cauldron
said cauldron it would be well first
we'd start with bark bark you know we're
going to take the river water the water
from the creek got to be careful with
bark cuz some bar can be very poisonous
Canadore who had his john to the point
got it I did while everybody's drinking
from the cauldron
yeah I'm drinking from the black sister
and okay and the black cistern uh clam
chowder usually okay I thought I thought
maybe some kind of a like that blood or
something like that you just got a clamp
ah Jesus I just got a clam is it I
understand you usually you like your
clam chowder raw I do like Rockland I'm
part of the raw food movement no I know
but I just we get people out in the in
the forest yeah and and that's and we're
in nature yeah that's where and where
and that's where we you know they're out
there they're there they're in cloaks
they're in the forest and these people
are literally having gay sex and coffins
okay they're swimming in feces okay is
is this Alex Jones Harris and your
friend Joe Rogan yeah who's literally
reading the George Soros talking points
and and he said he'd have me back on the
show I don't need to be on his show okay
well I am sundar Pichai the CEO of
Google yeah and Google is evil and you
know this because you're part of this
exact trap travesty is what I would call
it and it's a conspiracy on what people
who come to this planet just using it as
a search engine they're bad people
and their lizard's fat people and
they're not human okay do you have any
evidence scientific evidence for this do
you have any let me tell you the
scientific evidence that I've found of
bad people of above lizard people
[Laughter]
lizards living among us stuck and your
friend Joe Rogan yeah who and Joe's a
brilliant guy yeah Joseph Joe knows as
much as I do
amen and and he's a well-read guy right
and a nice and he's talking about DMT
and he wants to start a concentration
camp
no I don't go I don't think that strive
don't go a long time I mean where Joe
Rogan where lives up in Valencia where
he has a concentration live in Catalina
yes concentration tale I can tell you
that his George Soros that's not plant
I got a clam it's just like the story of
Scorpion and the Frog yeah I know the
Scorpion says hey to the Frog get me
across the water yeah and he gets on the
frog and the scorpion stings the Frog
yeah and the fan of frog says why'd you
sting me and he says cuz I'm a scorpion
it's in my nature
yours in my nature you're a scorpion and
a joke Joe Rogan is a scorpion all right
there's scorpion people thanks Alex for
joining us and that was a quick little
blurb by Alex Jones and I said Alex
Jones we had him on the PI we have him
on very small blurbs very bursty that's
too much he heats up he heats up the
room he literally heats up the room so
in his veins he gets these drying veins
and he's younger than me but bring up
Alex Jones for a second I want to I want
to just I just want to point out that
that kind of agro energy how it ages you
yeah don't take all those times now now
alex is 27 years old
yeah he's roughly I think he's 43 or
something that's him and there's no way
he's 40 yeah he's young he's a lot
younger than me but I'm telling you
that's it what's amazing to my chin haha
good are you
well now let's go ahead and look up Alex
Jones age because he's and take a look
at him now he's under some stress
because I think he's gonna be in some
Wow look at this you see he weeps let me
see it says weeps over Syria
all that's like so 44 oh my god he's
rock war dude
so I are kidding I am 8 years older than
him I'm 8 years old he's one year older
than me that's right that I I would have
had I would have thought he was 10 years
old I wouldn't I would have thought he
was 55 you sure yeah 57 and then and and
that's the offense of aluminum that is
in all of our medication I don't think
and George soon to sundar pichai yeah
who's allowing these communists in the
giant China to censor and edit okay so
that was more Alex on on aluminum chin
so he was creating the halogen oh you
have shown yet such sound Borden gets
kind of crazy oh we should play Alex
Jones soundboard that's right that's
right
make up frogs gay [ __ ] make the Frog say
hey take that stuff makes the frogs gay
that's it stop working and they're
making the frogs game two different by
well he likes to he likes to punctuate
that after we you know there are various
all they are as different versions of
making there is he's having a tough time
right now Alex yeah he's sweatin this is
what a real human looks like I like to
eat I like to have babies yeah I like to
fight
yeah chin yes congratulations to you we
crushed in the ratings did you really we
did that's great you're kind of cool
right yeah is the first time in my life
like so so so I was thinking about this
I'm 52 in January January 26 I'm 44 yep
chin it's okay dude sorry man buddy come
on
he loves to do loves algae loves that
button so I'm 52 and for the first time
I've been doing this business a long
time I started with MADtv 24 years ago
that show was on yeah that's true
thirty-six sir 95 95 I was in the
original cast yes you were so so in the
replaced or you replaced Chevy Chase
I probably did I was fired my second
year I didn't come back for a third
season and thus began a long journey of
me with of having a lot of almost as you
know as an actor yeah and then all you
want to do is just get one sitcom where
you can pay your bills and not worry and
just maybe buy a house all that stuff
and then 52i I get my spinoff yeah after
doing my recurring and and of course you
know that when you get a spinoff you
just go that's cool
this is 13 episodes thank you so much
and then I'll go on to something else
sure you know because nothing ever works
out Bryan Callen and it's all good
though
ask Norman fell who took his role of mr.
Roper from Three's Company and one on
the ropers and he said I don't want to
do the ropers yeah I want to stay on
Three's Company
yeah and they replaced him with Don
Knotts that played mr. furnaces history
and the ropers went on to do the ropers
yeah and it failed that's right and and
now if you look up kids if you look up
mr. Roper Norman fell during the ropers
he was 44 years old I didn't the same
ages Alex Jones I didn't know that oh
sorry you were saying so you wanted to
time write a wee-wee so we do the pilot
now again well they are pilot heirs I am
expecting because of the way my brain
works and the way these things I'm
expecting probably big fall probably
nothing probably
nice knowing you is great our ratings
are cued that's our way bigger name I
thought so it's tough it's a first for
me dude that's [ __ ] great you know of
course I can't relax into it but it's
it's nice no you're not gonna enjoy it
at all no but it's not us that's [ __ ]
awesome and it's like Bryan Cranston too
you know I mean there's Norman Phil well
you Keith Cohibas great by the way
he was [ __ ] Norman felt was the only
one in Three's Company who would do like
a comedic aside he would look right into
the camera
yes and then he would like look at your
dick and then into the camera and your
dick into the camera and he would do
this thing yeah I mean there you go and
that's a lesson to the kids out there to
keep plugging at it because they're
trying to bury us and thank God for
President Trump who's gonna take on all
this idea malfeasance and lying CNN I
think you can get Jim Acosta who's out
my wall saying whether it seems to be
peaceful by the wall you're standing by
a wall yeah whoa which in my sorry chin
yeah he went crazy on the wall thing
that's that's that's cool that's amazing
yeah it's so awesome
well show got good rain yeah now I'm
waiting for it all to go to come
crumbling down when I'm diagnosed with a
terminal disease I tend to go I tend to
go I can't enjoy anything yeah well you
worry about it too much
this chairs way too small look where my
clothes suede boots hey thanks a lot who
makes those suede boots
I don't usually no shoes unless they're
Brent and he wears candy on his feet and
I and I hate the way he dresses these
are blunt stones
I bought some blunt stones but I didn't
know blunt stone made oh you know they
got all sorts of flavor I was gonna say
you're not gonna get you're not going to
be stricken with a terminal disease
because psoriasis is not terminal oh
yeah and my soul oh good yeah a hundred
percent things are coming up roses for
Bryan Callen guys [ __ ] in Windows 98
[ __ ] winning that's my dad hold on
let's talk the Big Mike Big Mike
how do well our ratings were huge they
crushed much bigger than people thought
that's right so I may just have a job
for a while yeah yeah it depends it
really depends but but we retain a
hundred percent of our Goldbergs
audience so that was good is that you
were doing some real acting it wasn't
just all comedy it was you know you
reached yeah yeah I'm a talented guy and
I know that yeah and I and I understand
you take some credit in mixed company
when whenever you're talking about me I
I don't know if you usually say he's got
my genes
have to confirm that yes right
so I don't I don't say he's got my genes
it's me it's not him nothing like that
okay nothing you just put that out there
right I do I do
well see listen you know I'm tempered
you've been you've been in this journey
with me who knows who knows what's gonna
happen right by the way you're on my
podcast right now the fighter and the
kid I answered it I'm with my dear
friend Will Sasso and I am I'm mr.
Callen there he is there's a good sir I
do my dad doesn't remember you at all he
doesn't give a [ __ ] the pacquiao [ __ ]
you oh [ __ ] I owe you're embarrassing me
in front of all my fans I love pacaya
let's get some fish tacos you put some
papaya Big Mike downs one of the
smartest people I know and it just
proves it there you go
[Music]
no we had nothing but positive you
punched all right well listen thanks for
thanks for explaining that hit the
proper pronunciation of Pacquiao's name
is pacaya oh I didn't know that all
right well yes I actually did all right
listen listen I'm gonna let you go back
to your thing I thought you'd play you
you have that $5,000 golf simulation
machine in your garage which wasn't set
up and I was there because the back your
mind you crossed me too many times
you're gonna lose some body part
threaten me like that wait you said I
can lose a body part for Christ you
murdered him
this is this is getting really dark no
but I sent it to you to mine alright
well listen the people the people like
hearing from you so uh no I've been this
is a fighter nakeeran it's it's Lois
oh that's the bryan callen show which
i'm going to reboot and then I'll have
you on
yes I will bye bye
that's my dad he threatened me he just
threatened me proof positive that the
Kalen bloodline runs cold and it's these
are cold blooded aliens wait a minute
and I've seen it and you voted for
Hillary I voted for Hillary know that
she's evil no and your friend Joe Rogan
yeah who I love Joe okay and we go back
a long time that's right would not have
me back on the show and you were a
little crazy on the show and my Mike
Allen hi the same thing and he wants to
be on your program and you say you're
gonna reboot the Brian cabinet the the
the the
Jim don't play anymore my bad Brett
what's going on with you man are you
working on the shows you're doing
Loudermilk
yeah Loudermilk we finished shooting and
it's finished but you said you have to
be on set today I'm dumb guessing I'm
doing a few little couple episodes here
here and there of what Oh mom CBS
oh yeah mom you playing the mom with no
that's Allison Janney that's not funny
that's not that funny that's pretty good
yeah so we're doing that I'm doing that
right now yeah and then I'm working with
your dear friends Marshall Cooke and
Chad Kultgen of those guys on a new
thing that short that well Marshall and
I made it short and now we're all we're
developing it really Kobe that's a great
short with your boy Pete Farrelly was
nominated for something he won he won a
Golden Globe for green book Wow he
directed that yeah he directed it damn
yeah yeah he won a Golden Globe for Best
I got a song in the comedy musical he's
gotta be one of the nicest people I've
ever met he is the nicest he's one of
the nicest guys in the world now as a
matter of fact you know I I first worked
with Pete Farrelly on the Three Stooges
and I met him a few years before that
but just the nicest guy and one of the
one of the dudes who was in the Stooges
Christian Montopolis you know Chris yeah
he emailed myself Pete and Bobby
Farrelly and Sean Hayes who played Larry
in the movie laughs and we in and he was
telling Pete he was telling us about
this dude II ran into at a hardware
store and he told us his whole story
it's like oh yeah me and my dad used to
watch Stooges and he loved the new movie
and he said some complimentary things
about the movie being sort of like the
old Stooges and Pete writes back hey did
you get that guy's number I want to call
him cuz his father has passed away and
that's Pete like he's like did you get
the guy's number I want to call it great
deal just cold call people do you know
he heard a story about Pete and his
brother and I don't know which one did
it but his father Peter Farrelly's
brought father was a doctor doctor yeah
and so they're sitting down and they're
about to watch the football game on a
Sunday morning and Pete is like
hawk-eyed man I had such a night last
night and my ass is killing me this
father goes what and they
now my ass my ass is I don't know I just
I went crazy last night and he goes what
do you mean your ass is killing you guys
I don't know my [ __ ] is killing me I
don't know what the hell to do about it
and his father who's a doctor's like
well your ass the muscles are what he
goes now the inside the ass my [ __ ]
his father goes god dammit - well well
show me what that will show me your ass
what are you talking about so he peep or
what his brother bent over his father
got stuff what what the hell you know
he's he's dr. Boz a doctor he's like you
know you gotta whiz sons and he looks at
and and Peter's stuck a condom in his
ass yeah oh god damn it
god damn it they screamed like a god
it's not funny what are you doing sorry
was there something in there that's the
kind of family he grew up him he's that
the funniest [ __ ] thing you've ever
heard that's amazing
yeah I have heard that story yeah Pete's
Pete's good for a laugh let's put it
that way yeah he's good you know and
he's he doesn't really like it in the
same vein that he'll call somebody to
talk to them because he's a sweetheart
he'll also just hit you up to [ __ ] with
you and well I did it I did a charity
with you he's never done a charity dead
never did and he was in the audience and
I and and and Larry Kramer was there
what's his name Larry Kramer that's what
Larry and Larry Kramer runs a Seinfeld
Larry Larry David Eric and so they did
the auction one thinks the auction off
was a golf lesson and I was like you get
to play with Larry David and stuff and
and and it was we were raising money for
these sick children that were gonna die
it was very very kind of moving actually
and Jennifer Garner was there anything
and I'm emceeing the whole thing and
trying to sell off all this stuff and
Pete Fraley just comes up on stage when
nobody was buying [ __ ] and just takes
Mike and goes hold on all right enough
of this [ __ ] we got to raise money
got to do it now these kids let's go
Larry David is old he's not gonna be
around for long he's probably gonna die
in about three years so somebody better
[ __ ] buy up golf with Larry David
right now and that's how he starting
it's just an amazing guy yeah he really
is he's all fees all [ __ ] heart yep
there they are laughter I got somebody
was like
when I got stage I was like let me let
us be in your movie be in our movie we
love you so much
what movie hey what movie I heard your
what movie you doing you doing man quest
yet four years you've been talking about
shooting man well I got busy well yeah
but what about man quest I got busy
though you know sorry but you doesn't
talking about man quest for years yeah I
know man and I'm still work I just know
about man my own pace about a guy who
become goes from boy to man you know
that's something I'm working on boy to
man yeah and I don't need you i I don't
need you mocking my process I'm not
mocking your [ __ ] first of all you
don't have a process to mom hey I know
no you don't you don't have a process to
me yeah you just [ __ ] I go through
life the Goldbergs and then you whoa
this is you this is you getting this is
you carefully they're like oh hold on
I'm gonna tell you I don't I need to
talk about your process alright okay
I'll let me tell you about your pencil
and be honest I'm always respectful and
honest that is like someone who's like
but I can feel is what you do you go
like hey honestly let me tell you so
you're gonna preface this by saying
honestly which means the rest of what
you're saying is [ __ ] that's you
bryan callen chin yeah here's here's you
you're doing the Goldbergs it's going
great
and they're like oh we're thinking of
spinning this character off we're
thinking about doing in school and blah
blah blah and here's how you add to that
and you fall into it you're [ __ ]
that's your entire [ __ ] career Oh
ain't I wrote down my dream board and I
can show it to you I bet your dream
board is a cork board in your bathroom
and it's got three pictures on it yeah
there's a [ __ ] a canoe in a lake
there's a [ __ ] pair of suede shoes
and a little red chair okay why that's
what you got well why would all that be
on my dream board that's all you got
going on up here
I got a canoe in a lake what yes I feel
like I'm a canoe on a giant lake no
you're like I want to go out in nature
one over in nature and then you wanna
then you want in the you like nature so
nature is one of my goals yeah [ __ ]
going out in nature which is someone you
just you're gonna be hiking out there
amongst the the roots and rocks and you
and fall in the water and you wish you
had a canoe you better shut up or I'm
gonna [ __ ] punch you and I'd love to
see it don't I didn't flinch okay well
you know what that means I've got
somebody listen man don't I do the one
and I come in home told you not to do
not a defender I do know how to defend
myself
Jesus Jesus Christ that actually works
oh I came out of me man you scared me
you just got as a serious coward yeah
okay
you just got at it as a fart fart and
coward right that's not good for my rep
no it's why would you do that because I
didn't know that you'd be a fart fart
and coward if I came at you yeah but I
want look at me adjusting in this
[ __ ] chair man did your chairs over
there
defend yourself at all yeah well I want
you to think up a big tough guy and
you've exposed me it was a photo you
fetal DUP and started farting man fetal
farting keep your eyes open and look at
me encounter maybe I could do some fight
training it's all right so let's try it
again but keep your eyes open now just
please don't do it gotta [ __ ] stops
to please come on I'm not gonna hit you
just keep your head up and keep your eye
you're already [ __ ] I'm knocking
flinching and coward lessness when
people are cowards some really brings
out the mean in me dude had something in
my eye
you're a bully [ __ ] judo don't you
can have your eyes open to it
[ __ ] hands up
[Music]
[ __ ] oh that's did that to matter me did
that come out of me
that's disgusting you're a [ __ ] Oh
smells like [ __ ] human [ __ ] I was in
the oxygen out before it works I can't
even come out God did you please a
little [ __ ] healing me oh you're a
fart farting coward you're a human skunk
yeah
dude you're a human side home a big fart
and polar bear that was impressive
goddamn it stinks in here
so schooled out did school did good
school doubt yeah oh I have a question
ready
yeah yeah what are you doing stand up
okay when are you coming on the road
with me to do spam hey guys do you want
to see will sasso come out on the road
with me and do stand-up cuz I do I bet
you everybody does it would be fun
everyone you ever done stand-up in a
serious way because I'm not a stand-up
comedian well y'all we've talked not and
we've talked about this and the respect
I have for the game and there's people
off with your respect of the game I
don't people come up through the
trenches seem like people like you in
New York I don't give a [ __ ] people like
our good pal Chris D'Elia
remember over a decade ago Chris did 500
shows in one year yeah but that's what
he likes to do he wake up and let's not
paint him as a hero he woke up in the
morning in a turkey sandwich and then he
did a show at The Comedy Store in a show
at the laughs at his job yeah and then
he'd go in heavy criticism raising at
doing nothing yeah he's amazing at doing
only one thing like he can he can he's
the most uncomplicated human being in
the world there's a beauty in that and
sex and comedy coffee sex in comedy
that's what she's called what's what he
should call his next day yeah he's not
interested in anything other than making
being a silly goose and and that's
[ __ ] there's room for him there's
room for him in the world he's not even
into food yet he's into food he's not
really into food they're not anymore
because he's like working out and he
gets crazy about that but he's a piece
of weird
he doesn't need good gourmet food he
eats like shitty you know diner food he
eats turkey burgers yeah he's a turkey
burger eating
the [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah but guys like
that and I'm talking about people that
we know Bobby Lee who's speaking of
having a and you know a an elusive age
Bobby Lee 63 years old that's a rumor
he's doing Stan he's been doing stand-up
for like 49 50 years I am yeah and these
are people these are good friends of
mine who are the funniest people in the
world who I respect yeah and they do
stand-up now I I dabbled in some weird
live comedy [ __ ] early in my career then
you know then I was on MADtv early in my
career yeah I showed up on that speaking
of an elusive age I showed up on that
show when I was nine years old 19 you
got to be more I'm not
taran killam was 19 when I did manatee
in number 22 you're 20 I was 22 years
old so look at that picture of Mike
McDonald looking at Bobby Lee as the
funniest [ __ ] incredible
he's incredible Jesus so Bryan and I
were talking about Bryan was being very
generous he said once you come out on
the road with me and want you open with
me once you try some [ __ ] out yeah
now I was just on one of your cohorts
he's over here right Theo von yeah where
is he next door yeah but don't don't
knock on that just keep talking about
well he's banging on the [ __ ] [ __ ]
when he's I know but all right anyway
just stick to all right so Saeng so feet
and he was like oh you know once you try
stand-up bro you could be like you could
be out there with a bag of potatoes just
being gang gang and just like the I'm
working really good yeah you'd be out
there with a bag of potatoes and a and a
candid can of Cool Whip
yeah that's good so yeah so and we were
talking about it and I thought cuz I
used to do a character that did stand-up
we started it on the 10 minute podcast
David Greco yeah and then I would go out
and do this character but it's too
charactery right like it said why don't
you just you've got a voice Will Sasso
that's a good idea yeah but what if my
dad is a little sass up but what if I
did this yeah what if I did stand-up as
Will Sasso yeah but I call myself
something else great awesome just come
out and do stand-up as Will Sasso being
somebody else and I call it the guy
maybe he's something like
Jeff ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Jeff okay great
so Jeff and then I just look exactly
like me huh maybe maybe I'll just wear
some hip glasses okay I used to wear
glasses but now I got LASIK so you don't
wear glasses but you have you have
imaginary LASIK yeah where's some like
fake glasses got you like Randy Jackson
would wear on own no okay so you need
well you need is to hide behind
something initially American Idol mount
as a man in a matters why I don't matter
in a mask and do stand up yeah like a
Halloween mask just come on why don't do
here's why here's one of the reasons I
don't do stand-up I don't give a [ __ ] to
share my opinion with a lot of people
and I feel like stand-ups are true
stand-ups like yourself are born you
have a lot to say you have a lot of
opinions you know I don't got nothing to
say excuses for not making excuses you
could be one of the great stand-ups
right that's the that's very wrong
now you could well see pair of pair of
those pair those like come out come out
I'll tell you what feature for me
horn-rimmed ants lion mask what yeah
what yeah why don't I just be your Bryan
Callen swarm up I'll beat you gone to a
Bryan Callen yeah your G Kanto blood now
giganto Bryan Callen yeah and I come out
and rise your your nickname yeah and
I'll get a silicon mask made yeah and
it'll look like you people get freaked
out and I would pay I would pay $10,000
for I'll come out in a skin-tight
cashmere sweater
oh and and skin-tight gene I don't work
that don't die don't die Jess just like
you and a pair of kids [ __ ] shoes
what are those kids know they're [ __ ]
adidas a whole mother cute what are you
a size five oh you son of a [ __ ] ten
and a half so and then I'll come out
there's no no well what I lit here let's
be let's be real
yeah let's be real yeah okay and I'm and
I here's let's be real I well I'm busy
you're busy you're busy in Hollywood so
it's no excuse you're out there doing
thing yeah I just feel like if you
haven't done stand-up yeah if you
haven't done stand-up yeah and then all
of a sudden you run out there and you
start doing stand-up yeah it's kind of
like it's a cheat I don't like that
totally disagree no because look at like
guys like Michael Richards and then that
and then he's up on stage saying the
n-word now I'm not saying that's a
individuality of course I'm not saying
that's an eventualities for someone who
hasn't traditionally done stand here a
racist son of a [ __ ] so I would there's
a there's a huge probability that I'll
be saying the n-word Jesus at any point
when I become even a little fuss why
would you do and that's a risk because
being up on stage is no joke no but I
know and then I'm just n-word and we're
racist yeah that would be terrible
yes and then I'll be gone forever that's
right God forever banished that's right
to the forest having homosexual sex in
coffin all right listen with John Kerry
Jesus turn that and it's true I know
this so much Jim yeah sorry stop trying
to he's like hijacking the ship so
here's my thing it's like who's
primarily an actor I make [ __ ] that goes
nowhere and whatever and then you're up
there telling Zoey anyway and telling
jokes it's like stand-up is such a
specific thing and like I'm saying what
he's doing right now no I'm not he's
he's making whatever excuses for why
he's not gonna do stand-up like it's I'm
so bored with his long explanation I
don't you don't here's the thing
I don't want your audience going cuz it
is boring it's like no guy is gonna be
funny I know you know how to do that I
would like to hear I'll come out with
you we talked about this and talked
about this so I'm not trying to like you
know I'm not trying to get on the air
and do a bit I'm not trying to like
avoid what you were you talking about
right now yeah have a different
conversation than what we had before
right before the new year
Brian was like once you come out do some
stand-up with me I was like that's very
generous for you Brian cuz you know
Brian packs the house and I'm a great
guy and you're good so and that would be
fun I just I just I'm a weirdo and I
feel like creatively I would like there
to be something it's not it's not it's
not something to hide behind it's
something to make
get interesting for me so that I could
be great he dove I don't hey let's go
some curtain to talk about this [ __ ]
show
same thing happen on Theo show he's like
well what would you do Gang Gang and I
was like here's what I would do and it
was like so [ __ ] boring to talk about
it you got to do it well Alex you can't
just stand up comedy I want to do
stand-up comedy oh the juice your friend
Joe Rogan said that I could come out to
his concentration camp he didn't say it
Valencia understand all the people out
there and he's harvesting hearts their
organs no he doesn't that Google is evil
no that's not true
and they yep and sundar Pichai is is is
is is is is is is is let's go some
current events hurry this was a crazy
creepy one I'm sure you guys heard this
but oh yeah now right son random dude
Wow yeah just went up to a house he may
have obsessive-compulsive disorder so he
started looking at your bills to have to
lick all the doorknobs on his way home
if you ever read let's talk pretty
something that's hilarious
it's a great book David stairs head
person had he would have to lick all the
doorknobs and his mother's like you were
licking the doorknobs again and when
you're you have obsessive-compulsive
disorder you do these really weird
things like count every other square as
you're walking home and when you miss
mess up you have to turn all the way
back and start again they do these crazy
things so this is but let's watch this
one this one feels more like it's a
sexual thing yeah I agree I don't know
this is obsession if you had just a
[ __ ] pervert Oh something in his
brain I'll play this little news clip
for you so you could see it weird way to
ring in the New Year a home security
system
caught on cut an on camera look at this
guy a doorbell in Salinas police say
roberto daniel royal spent three hours
licking and poking around the yard the
homeowners they were out of town but
their kids were home and they didn't
hear anything
it was only when the surveillance system
notified the family and he's looking
directly in the camera outside that they
saw the bizarre behavior and they called
well that's [ __ ] scary oh who will
likely face misdemeanor charges poor guy
he's a realist for an electrical short
that is that is silly B yeah that goes
beyond - all I know is tongue I felt
like after licking a doorknob and one of
the cops say sir you gotta bring in
because you were looking at do it don't
don't like a doorbell well they're
saying they're gonna give him a
misdemeanor I mean I am Oh what are you
gonna do you lick my door my doorknob my
doorbell clean yeah yeah it is a weird
one well you're trespassing and not
really actually I don't think you're
trespassing when you sew so you're not
trespassing because what a UPS guy goes
up and rings your doorbell it's not
trespassing it's very good so but you
can a UPS guy ring your doorbell for
three hours with his tie don't know that
it was ringing it he was just keeping it
clean it's my point no I don't know that
he was keeping it clean he's making the
dirty with his filthy mouth yeah he was
also looking into the camera
periodically that is the creepiest [ __ ]
I am so creepy that's super creepy he
looks oh look he's going in when you see
God when you think about a guy your
children are home by the way you think
about a guy like that you just you're
happy you have guns and a mean dog well
ring calm ring is this thing where they
you know it's pretty widely available
and it's a you know it's a camera that
goes on your thing yeah what they should
do is put tasers in it in that little I
don't know if that would make sense or
put some of my fart gas in okay that's a
good idea
yeah yeah yeah yeah then he'd be like
he's probably a sicko oh you love good
if he would like to some lick my
doorbell
you could have come outside and grabbed
him and pushed your butt on push if you
were home with your girl or something
ant that guy was doing that what would
you do I would send whoever the I would
send the girl out there I forgot you're
a fart fart and powered I forgot about
that I don't want to go on well go out
there yeah no I'll open the door
cracking fart and when expose my and
exposed condom in my ass and then just
fart out a condom onto the thing I hope
that scares them yeah this is real
and and I love where we are in
technology I love two things I love
technology in the internet because not
only is this technology available it's
going to record them and because it does
they have a tough time get a job yeah
yeah cuz there's his name right there
and we can read it
Daniel Arroyo you never work in again
unless there's a unless there's a job
that you could do looking doorbells now
that's some good stand-up jokes now
that's good I got some dirty girls all
right let's see the next I was just
awful
alright this is a another one about
technology too so this is a Hong Kong
and IKEA to Hong Kong someone was able
to hack into their big monitor in the
front and show this guy masturbating and
the woman that was put it up on the
screen yeah they hacked into it and the
woman tried to instead of unplugging
some people are just full of mischief so
they're just it's a solo act
you know it's masturbating and then
you'll see the worker come out
[Music]
she gets a towel a towel they don't try
to unplug it gotta tell ya put a towel
over here you got and break that screen
right there that's a good idea but it
she's probably panic yeah that's
probably it probably fart you know
screen around it's not just yet that's
hilarious
yeah good [ __ ] and that should happen in
Times Square I can just see that
mischievous person just need what other
what other kind of sexually deviant
stories of the day that you got sexually
deviant um this is not so much but all
right I'm sure you guys know about this
too so Kevin Hart
you know the controversy about him
hosting that awesome I'm hosting the
Oscars and they haven't heard about it
was not aware so he went on Ellen
recently and it seemed like he was going
to you know be going back on cuz she was
like standing up for I'm gonna in a
certain way but it turns out he's not
gonna do it he's not gonna he's not
gonna do it
well what what is she it's not like she
can just say hey no I think she was just
trying to convince him like she has
friends at the academy oh I see he's so
awesome that that's that that is a loss
for the Oscars not for Kevin Hart
absolutely yeah well I mean it's like
and you know this is part and parcel to
my point Kevin Hart is a true comedian
yeah and he's out there saying if I am
[ __ ] around and I make a joke not
only is it something that I'd like you
to lean off of and just realize I'm
joking around I say a bunch of [ __ ] but
certainly don't go digging up my past
from ten years ago
and rather than apologize I feel like
someone in if this makes sense regular
wings of show business would you say oh
yeah I'm sorry but he has responsibility
so so sorry doesn't do anything so you
there's no such thing you can apologize
through you know to the moon and back
and you're still a piece of [ __ ]
according to yeah absolutely
there are just people who don't give a
[ __ ] there are people that are the and
it's usually those those eight holes on
the far fringes and they yeah they do
it's two five percent of people who are
pretending to be offended but the
problem rather than allowing human
beings to make flu
Nine's and as if I were all supposed to
first of all think and behave the exact
same way in order for us to get along
that's just not necessary
but you didn't notice the way I
apologized here's the way I would
apologize and I just did I would go I'm
sorry that's it yeah it's not scratch my
neck and I'm sorry right and and that's
just sort of like you just offer the
apology it's just as sincere as if I I'm
not saying I'm sorry and if they don't
take it for the problem if I was in the
eye if I was in his position yeah I
would've just said yeah I'm still sorry
and see if they took that yeah but they
won't because they won't and then by the
way what he didn't even have to I'm
sorry I'm cutting you off actin like
Branca um yeah I'm feeling just like you
when you yeah yeah but I know it's your
podcast but yeah but done okay but you
cut up you gotta have a lot of people I
you cut off with and we're I don't ask
people to come out and then you've got
the [ __ ] up no I don't know Kay but so
I'm doing it to you so I apologize in
advance for being like you don't say
that don't don't keep it that way it's
good okay yeah but the thing about the
thing about you know Kevin Hart yeah is
that he instead wants to you know stick
by his guns again you know because he's
a he was a comedian he's doing it under
comedic auspices and he feels like look
I have to protect the game I have to
protect the right of a comedic artist to
to say whatever and beat albeit it could
be wrong and it's a decade later and all
I'm saying is say yeah I'm sorry okay
anyway what were you gonna say
glad okay well no what I'm saying is
that whenever you have any kind of a
movement whatever it might be but let
Twitter is its own movement but
certainly like you you have these far
fringes and let's just take the far left
which I have a problem with its anytime
you have a group of people saying the
same things over and over again you are
not going to have room for nuance for
the human condition yeah or a mistake
and for correction you're just going to
have what's called ideology which is you
either
toe the line word for word or you get
disqualified destroyed just
you know marginalized and all that so
you know the people that are marching
for equality or whatever it might be are
just as tyrannical a lot of times how do
you mean it's well in if you don't toe
their line if you have a different tact
if you have more of a nuanced approach
and if you have a different methodology
you're considered the enemy and so you
are then marginalized and you are then
excluded and publicly shamed yeah and
they don't change anybody's mind you're
not changing anybody's mind you're not
persuading the other side over to your
side well you're just sanctioning that
you're just yeah you're sanctioning and
censoring two things number one this
chair is no more comfortable when I
recline okay yep
and the other thing I was gonna say is
you're right because it's like what you
said about Twitter as Twitter is unto
itself its own sort of breeding ground
for opinion and and it heads yeah and so
we're angry Pete I think for that reason
it it's really nothing to pay all that
much attention to because exactly
because it's like it's it's it's
something that just it just exists on
Twitter but there's no way listen don't
they huh
don't corporations listen to your app so
look yeah you're right you're right they
listen to the noise yeah I know they do
they do
but there's no way yet to sort of pull
what the general populace are thinking
until they put a chip in behind our ear
your friend Joe Rogan is implanting
chips so it's not as he is he's not
harvesting organs
he's got harvest in this Valencia and
he's got a bunch of black market doctors
are we he's got them doing Falun Gong
and found off a meditation that's
keeping their spirit clear and then he's
harvesting the organs and selling it to
George Soros who's vibrating words
around what's he doing with the Oregon
he's and those are being used for rich
oil magnates
oh and they're cauldrons yes in their
cauldrons and they're eating too much
fatty foods and pork and then
and then and then these health problems
and they're getting a brand-new set of
kidneys from your friend Joe Rogan and I
love Joe and he's a great guy he's
smarter than me but you're saying he's
got something he knows just as much as I
do
no and he's implanting into chips so
until chin I mean there's only a few
minutes left here can you so until you
you can't just pull the general
population so corporations you're right
are looking at all here's what's going
on on Twitter it's such [ __ ] because
if you just stop some on the street and
you go should Kevin Hart host the Oscars
[ __ ] a certain percentage of them are
gonna go who because they don't give a
[ __ ] and the show is over you watch the
Golden Globes then it's over yeah it
doesn't matter
[ __ ] anyway people win Oscars and
then they end up doing commercials and
shits right nothing matters all right
let me yeah let's get down to the next
day all right next one this is an
amazing rescue by a helicopter yeah
right here in the French ops did you say
right here in the French out right there
in the French I'm sorry he's not good at
all but check this out look how close
the helicopter gets the knowledge rescue
what look at that what oh that's crazy
yeah oh my god yo those blades are like
I know where this plates are bro I don't
have to have you come here
well I'm gonna tell you anyway very
close and here very steady hands dude
how about that how about getting rescued
how about that [ __ ]
hey don't climb mountains like that or
you die look at that [ __ ] yeah they just
scoop that down really fast I wonder
what happened in that incredible and
that's a drone because is gonna deliver
all of his Amazon deliverables by drone
and you're a sheeple because you think
that there's actually a person because
you grew up watching an air wolf shut up
Alex how is how do they get that I say
okay I think one of the rescue guys risk
was shooting it on the other side yet on
his GoPro that is badass
I've done a lot of rescuing and I never
do you know what one rescue name one
rescue you did that we would know about
don't make anything all about him I
don't I don't advertise when I rent when
I go behind enemy lines and rescue
people okay so what is top secret what
did you do did you go into the DMZ
between North and South Korea and I've
been there
do you have not been there with it oh
you would get ground up I don't know
what I said for fun I come in a
helicopter dududududu all loud and [ __ ]
you're just going by yourself and
slippers not on horseback bro horseback
yeah horses are loud or see Eagle see
Eagle fly on and eat sometimes because
they're quiet is fun so what do you do
do you have like shoulder harnesses diet
and I get missing my weight way down way
down right then I strap myself onto the
back of a seed you strap yourself to
it's me but that John can hoist yeah oh
you have to come in big ago and it just
goes yeah you're like Daenerys Stormborn
I am good Game of Thrones but yeah
instead of a drag I am that well that's
what your next show it should be a
administer I had
mr. medical you should pitch that for
schooled yeah that Coach Mellor yeah
coach wise was a seagull to work just
and it should just be you never draw
attention to it yeah you just have a
scene where like Tim Meadows has shown
up in like his car and then you show up
an eagle drops you off and then you guys
have a conversation
I didn't cold-open yeah [ __ ] you
never and you never call attention to
the next goddamn the next one is uh this
guy Jeff Bezos you know he fought for
divorce for his wife of 25 years and I
guess he didn't sign a prenup but it's
supposed to be split 50/50 hobo's do me
impossible she was an accountant at
Amazon before it was Amazon oh wow
so she'll be the richest woman in the
world and there is no prenup he was he
was it's funny if you look at him there
and if you look at him now what he's
done is he's hired he's been taking some
testosterone hired a trainer he's got a
stylist but oh is that an old picture
that was him back in the day go go back
to him again by the way you know look he
got he got he's been married a long time
he's got tired of his girl oh and if his
wife was initially an accountant at the
company yeah under the you know under
the the way that the divorce and and and
you know splitting up the money is is
governed currently she she deserves all
of it because he's a [ __ ] idiot
Harriet look at him there what we was
there oh that's hilarious that is too
awesome is he did he get a giant plant
yeah he's Jeff Bezos now he's you know
he's like he's got a nice cleft in this
job he's the man he went from being
dorky guy to being the man he's got
tight shirt on
was there a picture of him next Lee Rock
chin yeah that was weird I don't know
why they did oh that's hilarious look at
that that is so by the way then diesel
is shorter than Jeff besos and not
nowhere near as tall as a rock
that's hilarious I hate how they do that
in the movies they make Vin Diesel look
as tall as the rock he's pretty thick
though the rock is six foot five the
rock is erotic it's a boy Wow
what do you know I'll fight you I
the wroth and he inspires me to be tough
yeah he's a [ __ ] oh he does yeah yeah
but [ __ ] your human skull man you are
far farting cows caught you with
literally ten unanswered punches behind
the ear and yeah you kept me away with
it
God it stinks alright pause and full of
Ron Gracia Mackenzie benzos for all
business for all that money that's when
you realize how rich you are I know I'm
datin yeah if you lose one hundred and
thirty seven billion dollars yeah you
still got 137 bills yeah yeah who gives
a [ __ ] he doesn't care but that is a lot
of money to give away
damn but she'll probably have a
foundation he'll have a foundation I've
heard good things about doing all that
stuff I know somebody that knows him
that has worked with him you don't know
anybody who I know I'm friends really
good and he he's supposed to be a great
dude who actually is very very keen on
making the world a better place with all
his money that's good good
so why I'm like [ __ ] you and all you
do is take oxygen you know I don't yeah
you do no I don't you think oxygen you
shouldn't be here we're just I don't say
in America because I'm an American
citizen I may be as well as the Canadian
citizen first of all you're a foreigner
but second all no no I mean is I can go
why shouldn't be on the planet oh I mean
you should be but as I can go all the
way from the North Pole to down to
McAllen Texas till you wouldn't survive
one because I'm a citizen of North
America except for Mexico not really
what do you mean
Yanis is mmm citizen my you know mmm oh
yeah I'm an American citizen and I'm a
Canadian citizen I can't believe you and
I go wherever I want
I'm the South Roman Pole
in Mexico eatin Manny Pacquiao on fish
taco we watch the [ __ ] I know firefight
alright keep going alright this is a
little weird
Drake so this is back in 2010 mo kissed
a fan that was 17 years old however did
he know she was 70s you know he was like
how old do you after he was touching her
and then she's like 17 you all know I
can't go to jail and then he kissed her
after he did all that stuff
well not show you that video yeah it's
kind of like it's not like crazy but
well she looks like a child
so let's not ask her how old she is at
all let's say thank you for coming to
the concert and letter thank you
[Applause]
it's pretty long so he's massaging her
here why is there a guitar solo picking
up a Drake concert [ __ ] kissing her on
the shoulder neck alright our Kelly and
then right here listen sanity he didn't
know he didn't know nobody afterwards
I'll show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is she sick is he saying she's developed
she's fake why you look like that okay
[Music]
so here we go this is where it ends I
kissed her on the cheek it's fine no
don't do that
it was pecs on the cheek no yeah no he
was clearly you don't know that possible
so his history though so he's dated
girls that were a lot younger then
didn't talk about it and also that girl
from stranger things do you know that
controversy like they're best friends
you call and talk to her the girl the
little girl 11 Billie Jean or whatever
something yeah Bobby Brown Millie Bobby
million vibe around there you go Millie
Bobby Brown Billie Jean yeah in this
instance though they said this is in
Denver Colorado and I guess the consent
age there are 17 so it's not that
contracting in Vegas at 17 and and you
know I don't know yeah sure you don't
know you've got this well scouted yeah
you've got an app that tells you if I
could tattoo of all just not my Vegas
and just different number 16 eight yeah
I think it's much much ado about nothing
here's what here's what we should do
from now on everyone who goes to a Drake
concert at least 27 years of age yeah I
love a disturbing video disturbing video
surfaced shut the [ __ ] yeah I really
hate you really just say it's not
disturbing it's it's it well it's an
immediate even we live in a world where
disturbing there is some disturbing [ __ ]
in the world and people have to deal
with some real [ __ ] in the world and
this is American [ __ ] it's American
[ __ ] but don't kiss her on the lips
I don't think he did it looks like he
kissed her on the cheek he kissed her
cheek cheek forehead lips he did not
cheat you again I thought she can the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
be fine everybody will be fine shut the
[ __ ] up all of you so that's the
conversation Millie by brown was talking
to Laura about she said adding that he
is a great friend and a great role model
we just texted each other the other day
and he was like I miss you so much
and I was like I miss you more he's
great the 14 year old Brown continued
you're just gonna catch this [ __ ] I mean
you can't do a thing without people
reading into the worst possible
conclusion that's though that's the
Twittersphere it goes back to what I was
saying and I refuse to be part of it
[ __ ] off
or Kelly though you do agree with that
one he's a piece of [ __ ] and I said I
said our Kelly was a piece of [ __ ] when
I found out that he I couldn't believe
that that video I never saw it but I
couldn't believe that there was a video
of him pissing on a fourteen-year-old
now looked at me I didn't know that yeah
make sure that I knew he want to see the
germinated on women yeah I didn't know
they were chosen that's true because
when I heard that I wrote it off I was
just like you know see yeah yeah of
course I mean I mean besides me he's
he's he's gross yeah and when I heard
that a long time ago I I was like oh yes
I think when that [ __ ] started to break
Dave Chappelle had that you know he did
sketches about it and Kelly pissing on
the video which wasn't that in there is
a disembodied look in the grape victim
so calm daddy urinates in her mouth and
I start staring at great length on how
to position herself to receive his gift
I mean if so she was 17 it says okay so
I guess that's okay yeah Bryan Callen no
rules bride calendars open no goes to
Phuket Thailand probably with Jeff Bezos
until rogue won't believe the girl to be
14 at a time the tape was recorded I
don't know so we don't know but it's
bottom line is this I I don't want you
around me yeah you know yeah but the
both the girl and her parents have
denied that she and Kelly had sex it
sounds like it's a witch it sounds like
this might be a wishy-washy story there
was a video though I do remember there's
been a video and it was disturbing
there's a video of
now that we're talking about people
pissin on women there is a video of
Chuck Berry you ever seen that video
video yeah yeah yes you say he pisses on
a girl what he goes that deep sound some
[ __ ] like that that's all I thought he
pissed oh no it was him he's got a piece
on though alright next [ __ ] video I
thought it's not the quote the quote
that he had was I'd kiss you baby but
your face is all pissy doesn't that ring
a bell no write something Bryan dit says
every other day Julia goes I'm working
on selling a show for us thank me I just
got that all right this is a weird one
so Beyonce one of her fans she tried to
buy something she happens to be blind
she tried to buy one of her hoodies
online it wasn't able to cuz I guess
it's not equipped her website is not
equipped to help people that are blind
to use a computer
so she's suing her for the American with
Disabilities Act I mean this is so you
have a website that helps blind people I
don't know how to what else are we gonna
do here how inclusive can we all be I'm
so how is that how is that I hate should
I have a Braille website but it's how
it's like ultd it somehow speaks to you
as your you know as you're navigating it
I don't know how it works exactly
yeah that would but that wouldn't that
be an add-on or a widget or something
that you have because you can't see so
you would that makes sense this is
lawyers coming up with great ways to
make money but that has nothing to do
with Beyonce I know we're [ __ ] man
this is lawyers coming up with ways to
make we're all gonna move out to
millennia yeah I mean this is this is a
[ __ ] this is this plaintiff had a
lawyer friend who said let's go make
some money yeah that's the hoodie -
that's what it's the hardy she wanted to
buy holiday on see pretty cool hoodie
it's very green yeah I think there's
other colors - all right yeah there's
that I like that girl's hair she looks
like Bianca bel-air on NXT watching any
NXT wrestling no I hate watching oh why
not beautiful you like be on Bianca Bel
Air she's arrested I know Bianca Bel Air
hey oh I did hang out with the rest of
the other day a giant black gentleman by
the name of
huge guy titus O'Neil no keep going
Mark Henry [ __ ] buff
no keep going you [ __ ] I don't know it
could be anybody
you might not know was there keep going
brother
why don't you tell me his name shad
gaspard I know shad gaspard he used to
be part of crime time was a good guy
yeah we're gonna go out with him soon oh
let's all go yeah he's a big man and
we'll tell you about wrestling we'll
talk because I'm sure she had gasps bird
wants to hear about wrestling from the
valley watch I'm gonna have him beat you
up please don't do that why not
please don't do that Martin coward now
yeah I used to beat you up until you
fart everywhere fart farting coward yeah
fart first and I gotta go I gotta go do
I gotta go do my show well I gotta go do
mom we got a live taping in it all right
so we both got to do some acting well I
got to do I got to do I have to do more
how about I how about we end this with
me beating the [ __ ] coward addy
please to fade out on this no no no can
you keep your eyes don't please don't
now that's nap guys before we go just
know that I'm gonna be in Austin at cap
cities January 31st and the first and
second offender you understand about
that I am I've located what your true
standup I'm San Diego I'm not a fart
farting February 7th 8th and 9th and
then I'll be at the at the VOC theater
February 21st in France you guys know in
Vancouver I'll be up there so that I'm
an open for how come how about I come
and open for me okay but what if I get
scared
well no bleeding Cooper is my home you
fart fart new human scum this the part
of the kid
Oh chairs comfy when you do there